and you had to pick a sperm donor would
you choose somebody that was very
similar to you or would you try to like
look for qualities that you don't have
oh you have a brother you could use his
balls
[Music]
hey uh Regular Joe try to figure this
out why would a 38 year old virgin who
has never had sex be the father of 25
children because he comes in a cup and
women swallow it
and then they have a baby that way but
what would motivate him to want to be a
sperm donor because he's a virgin and
nobody wants to [__] his ass
so here's the crazy thing all the money
that this guy makes he puts it towards
charity like wow he's a good person yeah
I wonder why he's not married yeah you
want to know why he's ugly
it's actually not ugly but uh he's a 38
year old virgin yep if you're a sperm
donor and you have to be successful you
probably look pretty you have to yeah
like you that's true right because then
don't they want you
really
Christian boy he's a good Christian boy
not quite he goes I'm not [__] till
I'm married but I got a duty for society
so I'll come in this cup without
watching porn because then he's
Christian and then he wants to give to
charity because he's Christian yeah
the pictures are safe he doesn't
he doesn't jack off to women because
it's not his wife or like JCPenney
catalogs
LL Beans Ethan Allen Ethan Allen oddly
enough too some of the kids that he has
uh fathered from his sperm donation he's
like the Godfather of those kids that's
cool he has a relationship with a lot of
people do they know that that's the
father oh yeah so how can you be your
actual father and a Godfather
but why why would he want to do this
what would you think he'd want to do
this he he charity wants to have like a
father-son relationship with kids
but he doesn't want to have sex with
anybody is this is this an SDA thing no
it's not an SDA I think he's a virgin
he's a virgin is he asexual oh
he's never felt any form of Attraction
for men or women that's kind of time so
he's like the opposite of an absent
father because the absent father wants
to [__] a lot come and then run away and
he wants to not [__] at all come and
stay and so the reason why a lot of uh
couples he likes to help couples who are
having trouble with fertility but the
reason why a lot of these men want to go
with him is because they this dude
doesn't have sex and it makes them more
comfortable isn't that interesting that
is interesting yeah yeah
nah put this guy in office you're not
interested in that I'd be like I'm gonna
raise this [__] week come guys kid oh
I want my kid to be a [__]
not a not a not an incel get passed down
you think he's an ID cell
he doesn't hate women okay you're right
he's but but in cells involuntary
celibate right
so so this is not I guess it's voluntary
yeah well it's so he's a v cell he's a v
cell he he's kind of he's kind of more
cool it's an interesting life because he
understands I think when he was 20 he
figured out that he has like he finally
realized I have I was not born with the
ability to be attracted to men and women
so he really devotes his life to charity
and he volunteers with kids he sounds
like a really good person yeah it seems
like he is do you guys believe that his
I don't know lack of ability to be
attracted to men or women I think Nick
believes it he's getting skeptic you
think I believe it I just don't know
I think you do there's a lot of maybe
he's like a tree asexual right he wants
a [__] tree well I don't know what
I'm saying though what do you think a
person who's aromantic like if he's not
attracted to men and women what do you
think he thinks of to jack off but also
like one of your experience has been
from like
like you're telling me you've never had
any Curiosities or any experiences in
which that you felt some sort of
Attraction well maybe you got curiosity
yeah you never wanted to try and be like
but isn't the Curiosity even somewhat in
the direction of being attracted that
could be social pressure though it'd be
like hey like who are you asking in a
prom and then he's like gotta do it and
it's like yo did you like kiss her you
know what I mean like needing to feel
some sort of like weird pressure but
then being like I had zero feelings and
I didn't enjoy that at all and maybe
just discovering the aromanticism that's
like gay guys that had to have a beard
in the past because they're they were it
was socially very unacceptable to have
you know I think it's exactly the same
here wait say that again
you know in the past gay guys
Society so they would have beer beer no
a beard is is a is a fake girlfriend or
a wife that's like oh you meant beard oh
Tom Cruise and and like that yeah okay
so the beard the term for like if you
have a fake wife to just help you oh
yeah
did you know what I meant obviously
he's like I gotta I got a beard myself
I mean Anthony both have beards beard is
like uh yeah like what rock clusters
yeah and then sometimes like the women
know but they don't want to like let's
say like it's like a it's like a secret
that they have together because they're
like well I don't want to [__] go go
through this arranged marriage or
whatever like you'll be an old school
like Royal in France and [__] and then
you're gay as hell but like they're like
no you have to marry someone they were
like okay as hell I'm gonna marry my
princess friend because that princess
friend is is [__] from another
country and we need to unite the [__]
family no cause she she's also got a uh
like a Suitor that's like 60 years old
and she goes I don't want to marry that
[__] and then so you're like all
right well you could marry me and you
can [__] whoever guy you want and then I
could [__] whatever guy I want yeah and
then yeah you guys sign the papers they
do that [__] all the time yeah like in
in Hollywood isn't that like a thing
that's pretty common yep yeah the
interesting thing here is that it this
is a pretty unique case because here's a
person that has no attraction to men or
women but he has a desperate need to
want to be a dad that's why I'm like I
don't know and so eight out of the 25
kids that he's fathered eight of them he
has a regular relationship with where he
visits regularly two of them he will
have custody if something happens to
those parents okay what about their own
stuff yeah why so many kids those the
other ones the those parents declined to
like have a uh ongoing thing Fair they
were like that's their choice yeah
thanks I'm literally shooting this you
guys know anybody that is asexual or
anything like that I don't think I do I
think I do know one person do you think
that person is a hoax do you think
they're lying or are you there that's
true I do think that the the spectrum of
like unique experiences and
personalities exists so there's got to
be that possibility yeah for sure you
know what I mean so if somebody says
that then I'm gonna be like okay I'll
take it for for what it's worth yeah do
you ever ask for questions yeah like
what kind of questions like are you sure
yeah what do they say they're like yeah
that's it
that's great and then you go are you
sure
I would ask is like have you been on
dates have you oh yeah you know how many
days is it a guy or girl it's a girl oh
okay literally asked her uh um and you
guys will know who she is after the
camera and the lifestyle sort of
reflects that yeah yeah because because
you know being a curious fan of course
you're gonna ask all the basic questions
they've probably been asked like 100
times by their really really close
family and friends it's like well have
you ever tried this like have you ever
been on a day have you ever like looked
at this like you know what I mean have
you yeah so like maybe they have tried X
Y and Z but they didn't feel anything
actually she hasn't tried anything but
like genuinely has no interest yeah it
just doesn't even cross it doesn't yeah
it's just not there she never had a
crush before ask that too what'd she say
oh wow do you think you're like me does
she want to have kids everybody like
what
[Laughter]
it's just a funny question I didn't ask
that question for you let's say that uh
you were you had a wife and you couldn't
uh have kids with her and you had to
pick a sperm donor would you choose
somebody that was very similar to you or
would you try to like look for qualities
that you don't have oh you have a
brother you could use his balls
that's an option that's got a point so I
can't I can't have anything same
genetics isn't it like that you have
like uh like zero sperm zero okay so if
you have to choose from a catalog of
like Possible Oh if I gotta choose a
catalog yeah I'm picking the best thing
out there
what are qualities that you would look
for yeah
I feel like you have to be athletic okay
um
uh but what if they could grow up and
beat you up that's scary because they're
so excellent it's a very important
question so it's on the questionnaire
when you sign up every parent's fear
that's the first one well you know
you're gonna get older if you have kids
or anything your kids are gonna be able
to yeah at some point they can kick your
ass yeah no [__] way dude I'm not
going with that I don't again I wouldn't
know until I actually put myself in that
situation but I don't think that I would
be like interested in having that person
that donor have a specific relationship
or want to have a relationship oh yeah
you know what I mean No One's Gonna Come
that's definitely not a normal thing
yeah that doesn't normally happen and
then if they like asked to be like
present I I don't know how I'd feel
about it yeah I would probably I don't
I'm against it I'm already upset but I
can't I already have the kids so I don't
need you like constant online you're
like bruh okay I understand I understand
went into my woman but yeah yeah get
that ladder
foreign
[Music]